[Music]
jennifer joins us in portland oregon
jennifer welcome to the ramsay show
hello
so my issue is we have a 2013 dodge
journey with over 140 000 miles and it
has a lot of issues but it's still
running
and my husband wants to trade it in
for a newer vehicle with less issues
and i don't
see the benefit of that because it's
still working and running
and i don't want to go further into debt
because we're still on baby step too
okay what kind of debt are you guys
paying off right now
uh we have one credit card a couple of
doctor bills and the biggest thing is
his student loans
how much debt total
a little over 40 42
000 and what's your household income
uh right now it just bumped up to 70
000.
okay and i'm hoping to start work now
that our kids are back in full-time
school
okay so that will bring the income up
a little bit yeah okay so trading in the
car and the issues that's one thing but
what i would do if i was in your shoes
is just start a sinking fund for a car
you can pay in cash for is he wanting to
go into debt for a car
yeah he wants to get like a 20 000
vehicle and i just don't
see the benefit of that i mean yes it's
newer but we're still getting a used
vehicle with possibly more issues what's
his logic of of getting a 20 000 vehicle
i honestly don't know he thinks that
since it'll be newer there will be less
issues so he's sick of the problems on
the dodge and he's going man i don't
want to deal with any more issues if we
get an expensive car there'll be less
issues
yeah has he been on board with you here
his biggest fear is that at 170 000
supposedly miles
basically is like
the time tick
okay that's 30 000 miles away
yeah so can you not save up for a year
or two in a sinking fund and get out of
this debt and then get a car with cash
i think we could if we really stuck our
nose to the grindstone and did that
but he's not on board
with the baby steps in general because
it sounds like there's some disagreement
here oh yes
he's totally on board with it and we're
actually hosting a financial peace
university class starting next week
wow well okay so jennifer so here so i
think once this class starts he'll don't
realize hopefully
hopefully but here's what i think you've
got to do because he's on board can i
suggest that you cast a little vision
so when somebody casts vision right
their their vision casting
by definition is about showing a better
future right this is the future we're
headed to yeah and i think he's on board
with the baby steps but the vision he's
having a hard time with is
we got to have a more dependable car and
he's starting to go oh boy we've got a
law of diminishing returns here so i'm
going to try to change up the baby steps
and do it my way
what you've got to do is instead of
debating him on that i think you got a
cast vision to say hey before this thing
hits the 170 000 mile like don't try to
change the terms with him stay in his
narrative and go i here's a plan on
paper with my new job because i'm going
to be able to go back full time with
that increased income we can replace
this car like george is saying while
still moving forward on the baby steps
he's on board with that i just think you
got to show him
literally
how you get there
that would be my approach because then
there's no disagreement there's no
trying to you know knock his logic down
it's just like okay i get it we have 30
000 miles before you think man we've hit
the law of diminishing returns on this
car here's how we cash flow and replace
this car and don't go backwards i think
that's the vision
okay i can do that i know you can like i
can hear i can hear you got a little
juice don't you're like oh no that's a
different game and so i think that's
what you do
all right now listen you gotta put a
little sugar and spice on that okay once
you show him the plan then you gotta go
come on baby please please maybe make
his favorite dessert please do this for
me i'm i'm locked arms with you my
income's going up we can do this
and we can if we just stick our nose to
the grindstone all right i love it all
we got to do here is make that sinking
fun happen because we know that the car
is not going to be an emergency when it
goes out we know it's on its way out in
a few years but not tomorrow no so start
saving up on the side for this you can
you don't have to stop the debt-free
journey once you get some income coming
in you can get rid of this debt in a
year
with your income if you're living on
half of what you make you can do this
thing that's 42k the credit card the
medical debt the student loan it's not
going to be in your life a year from now
and then you can start dreaming about
that 20 000 car and save up and pay cash
for it but especially if you're going to
lead financial peace university for the
love do not get a car payment while
you're leading financial peace
university that feels icky ken i don't
like that one bit yeah it's uh so it's
definitely a conflict conflict of
interest you know it's funny though
george it's like just because you
level up
ten thousand dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars doesn't mean that cars are gonna
have problems oh yeah
plenty of uh twenty thousand dollar cars
with twenty thousand dollar
type repairs here it gets very expensive
very quickly